SO WE WILL BEGIN.
AS A SUBCOMMITTEE.
PERSIA MY COLLEAGUES -- TO JOIN
US HERE IN THE ROOM.
LET ME MAKE EVERYBODY WHERE
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR BILLS AND
AND FILE ORDER TODAY -- WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE WITH OUR
COMMITTEE PRACTICE OF FOUR
MINUTES ON EACH SIDE TWO
WITNESSES TWO MINUTES APIECE OR
SHARED IN SOME FASHION.
THERE ARE FOURTEEN BILLS ON OUR
FILE TODAY. SEVEN MEASURES WILL
NOT BE HEARD AT THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHORS -- THOSE ARE.
FILE ITEM NUMBER.
FIVE ASSEMBLY BILL.
SEVEN NINE FIVE BY ASSEMBLY
WOMAN IRWIN.
FILE ITEM EIGHT ASSEMBLY BILL.
THIRTEEN FORTY I ASSEMBLY MEMBER
Q..
FILE ITEM NINE ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN FORTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN.
FILE ITEM.
TEN ASSEMBLY BILL.
THIRTEEN FORTY THREE BY ASSEMBLY
WOMAN EGGMAN.
FILE ITEM ELEVEN ASSEMBLY BILL.
THIRTEEN FORTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLY
WOMAN.
OUR QUE HANNAH [inaudible]
ASSEMBLY.
FILE ITEM TWELVE IS ALSO BEING
PULLED THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR
THAT SYSTEM THE BILL. THIRTEEN
FORTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY.
AND FINALLY A FILE ITEM THIRTEEN
HAS BEEN PULLED AT THE REQUEST
OF THE AUTHOR -- THAT IS
ASSEMBLY BILL.
THIRTEEN FORTY SIX SO --
EVERYTHING ELSE IS -- ON TRACK A
LITTLE SHORT FILE.
TODAY BUT I KNOW WE HAVE A BUSY
DAY SO HOPEFULLY WE CAN -- MOVE
THROUGH THESE.
MEASURES.
AN EXPEDITIOUS WAY SO I'M
LOOKING FOR AN AUTHOR FROM THE
ASSEMBLY FIRST UP IS ASSEMBLY
WOMAN BURKE.
HE IS HERE COME INTO THE ROOM.
BRIDGET THAT.
ALL RIGHT THEN I I THINK WHAT
I'M GONNA DO -- THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WILK SENATOR WELLS HIS
MAN NOT DEVOTING IN.
SENATOR WILK -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
A MERIT SUSHI IS NOT HERE TODAY
I'M GONNA PRESENT HIS BILL ON
HIS BEHALF SO I'D LIKE.
TO TURN THE GAVEL OVER TO YOU IF
THAT'S OKAY.
AND I WILL PRESENT HIS BILL.
WHILE WAITING FOR AUTHORS
[inaudible]
YEAH.
AND I THINK THAT.
YOU YOU YOU GET A GAP.
CARE FIRST ITEM TO A. B.. TWO
FORTY FIVE MER SU CHI.
YOU MAY PROCEED MISTER CHAIR I'M
HAPPY TO PRESENT THIS MEASURE ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER --
THIS -- THIS PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU
WILL CREATE THE CALIFORNIA
AEROSPACE AND AVIATION
COMMISSION.
THIS COMMISSION WILL BRING THE
GOVERNOR AND THE LEGISLATURE
TOGETHER WITH THEIR SPACE
INDUSTRY LEADERS TO SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA'S NATIONAL AND GLOBAL
LEADERSHIP.
IN AEROSPACE INNOVATION AND JOB
CREATION.
ARE THE AUTHOR'S HEARD FROM THE
INDUSTRY THAT THEY WANT A MORE
CONNECTED EXPERIENCE WITH THE
STATE.
AND THEY WORKED A AND HE WORKED
WITH THE INDUSTRY ON CRAFTING
THIS BILL TOGETHER.
AS YOU ARE MANY THESE MEMBER
MEMBERS NOW -- CALIFORNIA'S HOME
TO MAJOR AEROSPACE COMPANIES
LIKE BOEING NORTHROP GRUMMAN AND
VIRGIN AS WELL AS A VAST NETWORK
OF SMALLER COMPANIES THAT
PROVIDE THE INDUSTRY'S SUPPLY
CHAIN.
THESE PROVIDE GOOD PAYING
MANUFACTURING JOBS THAT ARE
BRINGING US INTO THE NEW SPACE
AGE.
CALIFORNIA'S AEROSPACE INDUSTRY
IS BIGGER THAN THE ENTERTAINMENT
AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRIES COMBINED
AS MEASURED BY ANNUAL REVENUES.
AND WE HAVE A COMPETITIVE
ADVANTAGE IS THE SET US APART
FROM OTHER STATES INCLUDING A
SKILLED WORKFORCE.
THE SUPPLY CHAIN THAT'S BEEN
BUILDING AIRPLANES ROCKET SHIPS
AND SATELLITES FOR DECADES.
AND A HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEM
THAT'S EDUCATING AND TRAINING
OUR FUTURE WORKFORCE.
HOWEVER STATES LIKE TEXAS AND
FLORIDA ARE AGGRESSIVELY TRYING
TO LURE COMPANIES AND JOBS TO
LEAVE CALIFORNIA.
THAT'S WHY WE NEED THIS
COMMISSION TO SUPPORT AND GROW
AEROSPACE INNOVATION AND JOBS --
HERE IN OUR STATE.
I THINK I DO HAVE A WITNESS HERE
FAVOR.
DON'T SEE THAT SO WITH THAT --
MISTER CHAIRMAN THAT THAT'S THE
PRESENTATION THE BILL TODAY.
ANY OTHER SPEAKERS HERE IN
SUPPORT.
IN A IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NOW PULL BACK TO COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS.
THE SINGER ARCHULETA GOING THANK
YOU CENTER FOR PRESENTING THIS I
THINK SUCH AN IMPORTANT BILL.
WITH THE AEROSPACE INDUSTRY THAT
I BELIEVE SO STRONG HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
THAT WE HAVE TO THINK ABOUT
THEIR INDUSTRY NOT JUST IN
HOUSTON TEXAS BUT IN CALIFORNIA
SO I APPLAUD THE AUTHOR AND
THAT'S WHY SUPPORT THE BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
FALL BACK TO THE CHAIR I WOULD
DO WELL -- WHEN AND ADMONISH YOU
FOR ONE THING YOU FORGOT TO
MENTION LACKEY?
ON THE PRIMARY FACTOR AND THAT
BY THE WAY THEY'RE ALL IN MY
COMMITTEE I SHOULD IN THE 1% IN
THE BILL NOT YOU -- BUT THE THE
THE THE SALARIES AVERAGE
SALARIES A HUNDRED THREE
THOUSAND WHICH IS WHICH IS GREAT
AND THE THING ABOUT AEROSPACE
SINCE I THINK REALLY IMPORTANT
IF YOU LOOK AT THE GEO -- THE
HISTORY OF GEO POLITICS THOSE
ARE CONTROL THE SEA LANES WHERE
THE DOM OR THE DOMINANT ECONOMIC
AND MILITARY POWER SHINGO
THROUGH FROM YOU KNOW PORTUGAL
ITALY SPAIN ENGLAND WHATEVER.
BIDS BEEN UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
BUT IN ORDER TO CONTROL THE SEA
LANES BECAUSE THE TECHNOLOGY
UNIT NOW TO CONTROL SPACE SO
SPACES THE NEW OCEAN SO THIS IS
NOT A FAD BUT THIS IS GONNA BE A
LONG TERM TREND.
AND I'D AND I AGREE WITH YOU IS
VERY IT'S VITALLY IMPORTANT THAT
WE CONTINUE TO MAKE THE
INVESTMENTS HERE BECAUSE WE HAVE
SO MANY ADVANTAGES.
OVER THESE OTHER STATES AND HE
PICKED THE PERFECT PERSON TO
JACQUI IS BILL TODAY.
AND WITH THAT WE WILL TAKE YOUR
CLOTHES WELL THANK YOU AND MAYBE
YOU SAW MY CLOTHES BUT I I WAS
GONNA PUT LOUGHEED LACKEY DOES
IN MY CLOSE REALLY ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT COMPANIES IN
CALIFORNIA.
IS OF COURSE LACKEY.
LOCATED IN A REALLY SPECIAL
SENATE DISTRICT -- BUT THERE ARE
MANY COMPANIES IN THE SPACE ALL
IMPORTANT TO US ALL PROVIDING
GOOD JOBS AND HOPEFULLY
PROVIDING LEADERSHIP.
FOR CALIFORNIANS SO MANY
DIFFERENT WAYS IS BEEN EXPRESSED
WITH THAT I APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION TODAY.
THANK YOU SIR.
WE DO NOT YET HAVE A ARE.
THE CORN BUT WE WILL BRING THAT
FOR VOTE LATER AND HIGHLY
CONFIDENT THAT YOU WILL SECURE
[inaudible]
APPROVAL.
WE HAVE TO AUTHORS NOW.
ALL RIGHT WE STILL DON'T HAVE A
QUORUM YET SO -- WE'RE
PROCEEDING AS A COMMITTEE OF THE
WHOLE LIKE TO WELCOME UP ITEM
NUMBER ONE ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
THREE AND ASSEMBLY WOMAN BURKE
WELCOME.
THANK YOU AND MISTER CHAIR AND
SENATORS I'M HERE TODAY TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY THREE EVEN
WHICH ESTABLISHES A DEPUTY OF
BUSINESS AND WORKFORCE
COORDINATION WITH AND GO BASIS.
CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESS PLAYS
A VITAL ROLE IN THE CONTINUE
PROSPERITY OF THE STATE'S
ECONOMY ACCOUNTING FOR OVER 83%
OF THE NET NEW JOBS CREATED LAST
YEAR.
UNFORTUNATELY THE SUCCESSES
THREATENED BY THE POTENTIAL
SHORTAGE OF ONE TO ONE POINT.
FIVE MILLION QUALIFIED WORKERS
BY TWO THOUSAND TWENTY FIVE
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE WOULD
ESTABLISH A DEPUTY OF BUSINESS
AND WORK FORCE COORDINATION WITH
AND GO BATES AND ENGAGE SMALL
BUSINESSES ON THEIR LEVER NEEDS
TO BETTER ALIGN CALIFORNIA'S
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS.
WITH EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES IN
THE LABOR MARKET.
AB TWENTY THREE IS SPONSORED BY
THE IT DOESN'T MATTER ANY
CONSIDERING ANYWAY THIS BILL IS
RECEIVED CAN HAPPEN THIS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON WELCOME TO
MONDAY [inaudible]
MONDAY.
THANK THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER HERE
WITNESSES IN FAVOR A DEAL.
A LEAD THEMSELF ENERGY WITH.
SO LOCAL RICE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURES AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION WE'RE HERE -- AS CO
SPONSOR OF THE BILL AND IN
SUPPORT OF AB AT TWENTY THREE AS
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER STATED --
WITH THE EXISTING EDUCATION
SYSTEMS IN THE DISCUSSIONS IN
THE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT -- TO
ARENA -- THERE HAS BEEN A LITTLE
BIT OF DISCONNECT OF TRYING TO
GET THOSE VALUABLE RESOURCES --
INTO THE HANDS OF BUSINESSES
ESPECIALLY SMALL BUSINESSES AS
WE STATED IN OUR SUPPORT LETTER
THAT OFTENTIMES SMALL BUSINESSES
JUST DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES TO
BE ABLE TO GO OUT AND MAKE THOSE
CONNECTIONS IN THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS.
HOWEVER THEY DO HAVE A
FAMILIARITY WITH THE OFFICE OF
THE MALL BUSINESS ADVOCATE AND
ALSO HISTORY WITH GOING TO GO
THIS -- TO BE ABLE TO HELP THEM
NAVIGATE -- WHAT CAN BE KIND
SOMETIMES A DIFFICULT?
STATE SYSTEM SO THIS BILL IS
GOING TO PROVIDE IN THAT -- TO
SMALL OFFICE OF SOME OF THE
OFFICE OF SMALL BUSINESS
ADVOCATE.
A POSITION FOR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT SO THEY CAN HELP
COULD BE THAT BRIDGE BETWEEN THE
SMALL BUSINESSES AND ALSO THESE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT SYSTEMS
AND EDUCATION SYSTEMS. TO HELP
THEM BETTER -- COORDINATE THEIR
ACTIVITIES A FINE WHERE THOSE
RESOURCES ARE LOCATED AND REALLY
BE ABLE TO TALK TO THEM IN A WAY
THAT THE SMALL BUSINESSES
UNDERSTAND SO THAT THEY CAN
WORKING GET THEIR JOB THEIR
WORKFORCE NEEDS MET -- SMALL
MANUFACTURERS ARE WE'RE HEARING
THIS ALL THE TIME FOR THEM FROM
THOSE ENTITIES AND SO BEING ABLE
TO PROVIDE THIS WILL BE AN
ADDITIONAL STEP AND RESOURCE --
WITH A IN THE SYSTEM BUT DOESN'T
TAKE -- ANY ADDITIONAL.
REVENUE FROM THE STATE OR TO
ACCOMPLISH THIS OR MESS WITH THE
CURRENT STRUCTURE OF THE SYSTEM
SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE ARE
SUPPORT AND SPONSORS OF THE BILL
THANK YOU YOU ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN FAVOR.
A GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR MY
NAME IS ERIC FLOOR AS I'M HERE
ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING THE FORTY FIVE
LOCAL WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD'S IN CALIFORNIA.
A FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE OVER THE
FAST FIVE YEARS WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT SYSTEMS NATIONWIDE
IN CALIFORNIA HAVE MADE REALLY
HUGE LEAPS AND BOUNDS AND
CONCERTED PROGRAMMING
PARTNERSHIPS AND COHEN ROMAN.
OF THE CORRECTION SOCIAL
SERVICES ADULT EDUCATION
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS OF ALL WORK
TOGETHER TO ALIGN LOCAL AND
REGIONAL PLANNING PROCESS EASE --
TO THIS AND WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY THREE BECAUSE THE
PIECE THAT'S BEEN LEFT OUT OF
THAT IS THE OFFICE OF THE SMALL
BUSINESS ADVOCATE AND THE
BUSINESS SERVICE SYSTEMS.
OF THE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD IN CALIFORNIA SO OVER ONE
POINT THREE MILLION CUSTOMERS
WALK THROUGH THE DOORS OF OUR
CAREER CENTERS IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND PROVIDED
SERVICES ALMOST THIRTY THOUSAND
INDIVIDUAL EMPLOYERS WE FEEL
THAT AB TWENTY THREE WITH A LINE
THOSE SYSTEMS MUCH MORE
EFFECTIVELY AND ALLOW US TO
BETTER SERVE THOSE THREE POINT
NINE MILLION SMALL BUSINESSES IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE EMPLOYEE ALMOST 50% OF THE
STATE'S WORK FORCE.
GET THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN FAVOR
COME TO THE MICROPHONE.
THE CASHIER AFFILIATION.
IMAM MAJID WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNICATIVE CHANCES OFFICE OUR
OFFICE DOES NOT YET HAVE A
FORMAL POSITION ON THIS BILL --
BUT WE'RE SUPPORT OF THE
AUTHOR'S INTENT AND WE HOPE TO
HAVE A FORMER SUPPORT POSITION.
NEXT MONTH AT A BOARD OF
GOVERNORS MEETING THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
KAREN SARKISIAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
PLUS SHEPHERD ON BEHALF OF THE
CAL ASIAN HAMBER OF COMMERCE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NOW WILL BRING THE MATTER
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
DISCUSSION QUESTIONS.
I SHARE.
JACK.
I JUST WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
AND AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME I
WOULD LOVE TO BE ADDED ON
ETHICAL THANK YOU.
THE OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
ALL RIGHT -- WE BEFORE WE FLY
YOU TO CLOSE AT WE HAVE A QUORUM
HERE SO LET'S TAKE THE ROLAND.
THE OFFICIAL.
GLAZER HERE GLAZER HERE CHIANG.
CHING HERE ARE TO LET US YOUR
ARTS LETTER HERE DOT.
GALGIANI HILL SO HERE LEYVA.
THEY WERE HERE PAN WILK
PRESIDENT OF CARE OKAY WE HAVE A
QUORUM PRESENT I THINK I DID
HEAR A CENTER LEYVA.
MOVE THE BILL WITH THAT WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE AND I I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
THIS BILL IS A PRODUCT OF I AM
STILL CHAIR OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION AND BUILDING A TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY WORKFORCE IN THIS
BILL IS A PRODUCT OF THE
MEETINGS.
THAT WE HAVE DONE UP AND DOWN
THE STATE OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS -- IT'S THE REQUEST THAT
WE GET EVERY HEARING WE DO AND
SO WE'RE JUST HAPPY TO BRING.
IT TO FRUITION THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY WOMAN THANKS FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN THIS AREA.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION THAT THE
SECRETARY WOULD CALL THE ROLL.
MISSION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE GLAZER
AYE GLAZER AYE CHIANG.
CHING AYE ARCHULETA.
OUR TO LET AYE DODD GALGIANI
HILL.
HILL AYE LEYVA LIVE AYE PAN WILK.
I WILL GUIDE.
I WE HAVE THE TWENTY OF US TO
MOVE THE BILL APPLE WILL HOLD IT
OPEN FOR AB THANK YOU THANK YOU
PAUL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OUR MEMBERS WE DID HEAR US --
THE ITEM NUMBER TWO BEFORE SOME
ARRIVED -- AB.
TWO FORTY FIVE WE HAVE A MOTION
TO APPROVE -- EIGHTY TWO FORTY
FIVE TO PASS THE SENATE
GOVERNMENTAL.
ORGANIZATIONS AND WITH THAT --
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL GLAZER
HI GLAZER AYE CHIANG.
CHING AYE ARCHULETA ARE TO LET
AYE DODD GALGIANI HILL.
HILL AYE LEYVA.
LIVE AYE PAN WILK.
I WILL BY OUR THAT HAS PLENTY OF
US TO GET APPLE HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHEN.
IS HERE THIS IS ITEM NUMBER.
FOUR ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE TO
DISCLOSE INFORMATION TO SEE A
DOCTOR OR RESCUE GROUP.
EVERY TIME THE ANIMAL IS
TRANSFERRED OR ADOPTED OUT
ACCORDING TO STAY FOR INSURANCE
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS EXPERIENCE
MORE DOG BITES IN ANY OTHER%
STATE AND OUR COUNTRY.
PROVIDING THIS CRITICAL
INFORMATION TO SEE A DOCTOR OR
THE RESTAURANT GROUP WILL
EMPOWER THEM TO MAKE THE MOST
AND BEST INFORMED DECISION THE
CARRIAGE FORCES FOR THAT DOG.
IS REDUCE THE NUMBER OF FAIL
PLACEMENTS FOR THE DOGS AND
PROVIDE CRITICAL INFORMATION TO
THOSE WHO SEEK TO REHABILITATE
EVERY CHANGE.
DOGS THAT MAIN THROUGH NO FAULT
OF THEIR OWN BE FOOD AGGRESSIVE
OR FEARFUL OF PEOPLE.
HERE WITH ME TO TESTIFY AND
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MAY HAVE THIS KAREN L<c.cyan>G WHO</c>
REPRESENTS THE CALIFORNIA ANIMAL
WELFARE ASSOCIATION.
GET WITNESS IN FAVOR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAMBERS
CAROLING UNDER THE CALIFORNIA
ANIMAL FOR A CESSATION IT'S THE
ORGANIZATION THAT REPRESENTS THE
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE SHELTERS IN
CALIFORNIA.
MOST SHELTERS DO THIS IS A
MATTER OF BEST PRACTICE WERE --
BRINGING IN THE RESCUES TO THE
MEASURE AND SOMETIMES I
TRAGEDIES TO A CAR AND CHILDREN
AND SENIORS AND WILL MOST LIKELY
TO SUFFER A DOG BITE.
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS
PREVENT THAT FROM OCCURRING AND
BY TRAINING THE OWNERS THAT ARE
TALKING ANIMALS THE PERHAPS THE
DOG'S FOOD AGGRESSIVE BECAUSE
THEY MAYHAVE BEEN STARVED?
SO MAYBE JUST DON'T LET A CHILD
NEAR THE DOG'S FOOD BOWL FOR
EXAMPLE AND THEN YOU COULD
PREVENT A TRAGEDY OR PERHAPS THE
DOGS AFRAID OF BIG LOUD MEN AND
YOU MIGHT WANT TO JUST.
THAT WOULD BE THE BEST PLACE FOR
AHOUSE AND SO -- FOR DOGS WHO
WERE JUST TRYING TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE MATCH IS CORRECT SO
THAT WE DON'T HAVE ANIMALS
COMING BACK WHICH THEN TAKES THE
BAD FOR DOG THAT'S COMING IN THE
FRONT DOOR AND SOMETIMES ALTERS
ARE FULL.
WHAT WE'RE REALLY TRYING TO DO
IS JUST STABILIZE THE THE DOG ON
THE WAY OUT THE FIRST TIME THE
SUCCESSFUL PLACEMENT AND PREVENT
TRAGEDY?
AND THERE HAVE BEEN AN INCREASED
NUMBER OF DOG BITES AS A PART OF
AT THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH.
AND SO WE'RE HOPING THAT THIS
MEASURE WILL.
SEE THAT TREND REVERSES FASTER
EITHER TODAY THANK YOU.
GOOD THANK YOU MISS LANG ANY
OTHER WITNESS IN FAVOR.
THE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
BRING A LETTER BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ANYBODY.
SAY THANK YOU TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL THANK YOU
FOR ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS
WHICH IS TRY.
TO PROVIDE THE RIGHT -- TO
CALIBRATION ON AYE A GOOD BILL
LIKE THIS AND WE CAN ASSURE
ANYONE IS SAYING CLOSING.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR IPHONE I
HEARD CENTER LEYVA MOVE THE BILL.
AND SO WITH THAT THE SECRETARY
WOULD CALL THE ROLL.
MISSION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
GLAZER AYE GLAZER AYE CHANGBAI
CHIANG AYE ARCHULETA.
OUR TO LET AYE DODD.
GALGIANI HILL.
HILL AYE LEYVA.
THEY'VE AYE PAN WELL.
IT WILL GUIDE THERE'S A VOTE TO
MOVE THAT BILL APPLE WILL HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU YOU MUST REMEMBER.
OKAY WE'RE LOOKING FOR AUTHORS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLANCO BLANCA
RUBIO.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES SAWYER.
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER OBERNOLTE.
YOU ARE BETWEEN US AND LUNCH SO.
FOR SOME OF US.
WE HOPE THAT YOU ARRIVE SOON.
WELL THAT WATER THAT WILL BE IN
SHORT RECESS
.
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE A AN AUTHOR
HAS ARRIVED.
THAT WE'RE GONNA MOVED OUT TO
FILE ITEM.
FOURTEEN ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN
TWENTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OBERNOLTE THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE.
AND THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THE NUMBERS AB FOURTEEN WOULD.
ESTABLISH IN STATURE WITH THE
FEES CURRENTLY SET BY THE BUREAU
CANNABIS CONTROLS WERE EARLIER
REGARDING THE REGULATION OF
CANNABIS -- IF YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT ALL THE FEES UNDER THE
BUREAU OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS OVER
90% OF THEM ARE STABLE CHIN
STATUTE THIS WOULD ESTABLISH
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT OVER
THERE'S FEES WHICH I THINK IS
VERY APPROPRIATE.
LIKE TO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND YOUR STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
ME ON THE BILL.
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS OUTLINES
THREE TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS WERE
HAPPY TO TAKE THOSE AND I'D BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THAT YOU HAVE.
VERY GOOD ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT YES COULDN'T PACK
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AMY JENKINS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION --
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL TODAY --
THE PROPOSITION PROP SIXTY FOUR
GAVE CANNABIS LICENSING AGENCIES
BROAD AUTHORITY TO SET FEES
THROUGH THE REGULATORY PROCESS
WITHOUT.
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT AND THIS
IS REALLY MEANT FOR THE LAST FEW
YEARS ARE EMERGING INDUSTRY HAS
HAD TO REMAIN FLEXIBLE AND ADAPT
QUICKLY AS STATE REGULATORY FEES
WERE DRAFTED AND MODIFIED.
SO WE APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT
THE OFFICE OF ADMINISTRATIVE LAW
HAS FINALLY -- ADOPTED.
REGULATIONS.
WE WOULD LIKE TO SIMPLY CODIFY
THESE FEES -- SO WE CAN BRING
THE CANNABIS INDUSTRY IN LINE
WITH ALL THE OTHER BUSINESSES
OVERSEEN BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS -- WE ALREADY
FACE A MYRIAD OF CHALLENGES THIS
BILL PROVIDES CANNABIS
BUSINESSES THE SAME PEACE OF
MIND AND STABILITY GRANTED TO
OTHER BUSINESSES THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
JENKINS ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
FAVOR.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
I WILL BRINGTHE MATTER BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS AT THE CENTER LEYVA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR GOOD
AFTERNOON I JUST HAD A QUESTION
I BELIEVE THERE'S A REPORT
COMING OUT ON JULY FIRST IT'S
GOING TO LET US KNOW IF THE FEES
WERE CHARGING NOW ARE ADEQUATE.
IF THEY'RE INADEQUATE IS THAT
CORRECT.
YES SO WOULD WE NOT WANT TO WAIT
UNTIL THAT OUR REPORT COMES OUT
HERE'S MY CONCERN IF WE SET A
FEE NOW AND THE REPORT COMES OUT
AND SAYS THAT THE FEES ARE
ADEQUATE.
THEN IT COMES BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE NOBODY LIKES TO VOTE
ON ANYTHING THAT INCREASES FEES
OR TAXES.
SO WOULD WOULD WE JUST BE BETTER
SERVED IF WE JUST WAIT A LITTLE
WHILE BECAUSE THE BILL THE
REPORT COMES OUT A COUPLE WEEKS
FOR THAT HAD OCCURRED TO ME AS
WELL -- THE BUT THAT THIS
INDUSTRY FACES THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGE FROM THE BLACK MARKET
THERE ARE SEVERAL BILLS PENDING
IN THE LEGISLATURE THAT WOULD
ACTUALLY -- INSTITUTE A HOLIDAY
ON THOSE FEES BECAUSE OF THESE
ENORMOUS PROBLEM THAT WE HAVE
WITH ENFORCEMENT IN THE BLACK
MARKET IN TRYING TO GUIDE.
CONSUMER ACTIVITY INTO THE LEGAL
CHANNELS SO -- MY RESPONSE TO
THAT WOULD BE IT I WOULD SAY IT
IS EXTREMELY UNLIKELY THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD -- OR EVEN THE
GIRL CANNABIS CONTROL WOULD ACT
TO RAISE THOSE FEES ANYTIME IN
THE NEAR FUTURE.
AND IN INDEED WE MAY BE OUR BE
REDUCING THEM IF SOME OF THESE
BILLS PASSED SO WE'RE JUST
TRYING TO STABLISH THE CURRENT
AMOUNT AS MAXIMUMS.
AND NOT TO SAY THAT THEY CAN'T
GO UP IN THE FUTURE BUT I THINK
THAT IT'S APPROPRIATE FOR US TO
HAVE LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT OVER
THE RECEIPT THESE BECAUSE WE'RE
THINKING OF THE BIG PICTURE I
MEAN THE BUREAU CAMPUS CONTROL
THE THINKING ABOUT THE AMOUNT OF
REVENUE THAT THEY NEED. TO DO
THEIR JOB OF REGULATING THE
INDUSTRY WE'RE LOOKING AT THE
AMOUNT OF A FEE STRUCTURE THAT
WE NEED TO CHANNEL THIS ACTIVITY
INTO LEGAL CHANNELS AND TO TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE WE HAVE A A
FLOURISHING INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA SO I THINK IT'S
EXTREMELY UNLIKELY.
THAT ANY WOULD WOULD WOULD AGREE
THAT THE GREATER FEES ARE A GOOD
IDEA AND IN FACT WE MAY BE
HAVING DISCUSSION ABOUT LOWERING
THOSE FEES.
WELL I THINK THAT'S VERY
OPTIMISTIC -- ONLY BECAUSE THIS
IS SUCH A NEW INDUSTRY AND AND
WE DON'T KNOW THAT THE FEE
STRUCTURE WE SET IS ACTUALLY
WORKING BUT WE WILL KNOW THAT IN
TWO WEEKS ACTUALLY YEAH IN
EXACTLY TWO WEEKS.
WOULD YOU BE OPEN TO YOU KNOW A
TO AMENDING THE BILL OR SAYING
THAT YOU KNOW WHEN WE GET THIS
IN JUST TWO WEEKS SO WE HAVE
PLENTY OF TIME.
THAT YOU WOULD LOOK AT THAT AND
SAY HEY MAYBE WE NEED TO
RESTRUCTURE IT.
I'VE WE WILL CERTAINLY BE
LOOKING AT THAT I THINK THAT WE
ARE DOUBLE REFERRED IS THAT
RIGHT.
I THINK YOU'RE SEEING SO HARD.
OKAY PROBES OKAY FILLED WITH
FISCAL IMPACTS OF THE CONCERN IS
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE CALENDAR
BUT I'M SURE THAT I MEAN
OBVIOUSLY TWO WEEKS WE'RE NOT
GOING TO CLEAR.
THE SENATE CHAMBER AND I'M SURE
THAT'S A DISCUSSION THAT WE'RE
GOING TO BE HAVING WE WANT TO BE
PART OF THE SOLUTION TO THE
PROBLEM WE'RE TRYING NOT TRY TO
MAKE THINGS WORSE HERE.
OKAY ALL RIGHT THANK YOU READ
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
CENTER ARCHULETA.
YES IN REFERENCE TO FEES.
THE MEDIA UNDERSTAND THIS SHOW
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THE FEES WILL BE SET.
WHAT ABOUT THE THE COUNTIES AND
CITIES WITHIN THE STATE ARE THEY
GOING TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
ADJUSTMENTS -- AT ALL IN THEIR
FEES ARE THEY'LL BE NO FEES
EXPLAIN TO ME HOW THE CITIES IN
THE COUNTIES WILL FALL INTO PLAY
WITH THIS WELL A ROOM -- IS.
QUITE A COMPLEX PIECE OF
LEGISLATION AND ESTABLISHES KIND
OF A PATCHWORK QUILT OF
STATEWIDE REGULATIONS AND THEN
REGULATIONS THE PERMIT LOCAL
CONTROL SO WE'RE JUST TALKING
ABOUT THE FEES.
THAT -- THE STATE WIDE A BUREAU
CANNABIS CONTROL HAS AUTHORITY
OVER SO THE CITIES AND COUNTIES
CAN STILL IMPLEMENT ADDITIONAL
FEES WE'RE NOT TAKING ANY
AUTHORITY AWAY FROM THE CITIES
AND COUNTIES.
CAN VERY GOOD THAT ANSWERED MY
QUESTION THANK YOU ANYTHING ELSE
FROM HER COLLEAGUES.
OKAY I I DO NOTE THAT THAT
REPORT IS SOUGHT.
ONLY AFFECTS THE BUREAU.
IT'S NOT KNOWN WHETHER SIMILAR
REPORTS ARE GOING TO BE MADE.
FOR DEPARTMENT OF OF FOOD IN AG.
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH RIGHT TO THIS IS THIS.
BUT I APPRECIATE YOU BEING
SENSITIVE TO CENTER LIFE IS
POINT HAS THAT AS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD.
I WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO GIVE YOU
THE OPPORTUNITY CLOSE
GRANDFATHERED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION AND
THE ROBUST DISCUSSION SOME GREAT
QUESTIONS WERE ASKED AND JUST TO
BE CLEAR.
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO HEAR IS TO
ESTABLISH LORD LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT OVER THOSE FEES AND
THIS IS NOT A UNIQUE SITUATION
MOST OF THE FEES UNDER THE
JURISDICTION OF APARTMENT
CONSUMER AFFAIRS HAVE THIS KIND
OF OVERSIGHT?
WE'RE JUST SAYING THAT THESE FEW
SHOULD BE NO DIFFERENT I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST RIVAL.
FORGET THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
THE VICE CHAIR CHIANG IS MOVE
THE BILL THAT THE SECRETARY
WOULD CALL THE ROLL THIS IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED.
THANK YOU FOR TAKING THIS
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS THAT THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS.
GLAZER AYE GLAZER AYE CHIANG.
CHING AYE ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA AYE DODD.
I GALGIANI.
FILLED.
HILL AYE LEYVA [inaudible]
PAN.
HI CAN I WILK HI WILL GUIDE.
I THAT HAS -- DEVOTES DIVINE BUT
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OF CONTRACTS
TO MEMBERS THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU FOR FOR
COMING AND PRESENTING YOUR BILL.
RIGHT NEXT UP I HAVE A FILE ITEM.
SIX ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE SIXTY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLY WOMAN
PETRIE-NORRIS.
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE GOOD
MORNING WELCOME TO BEGIN AS AS
YOU ARE READY.
GOOD MORNING THAT CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M HERE THIS MORNING TO
ASK YOUR SUPPORT FOR AB TWELVE
SIXTY FOUR THIS BILL CLARIFIES
VAGUE TELEHEALTH Là.
IN ORDER TO EXPAND ACCESS TO
BIRTH CONTROL USING SMARTPHONE
TECHNOLOGIES.
AS WE ALL KNOW BIRTH CONTROL
ALLOWS PEOPLE TO CHOOSE IF AND
WHEN TO START A FAMILY SAFE AND
EFFECTIVE FAMILY PLANNING.
HAS AFFORDED WOMEN ECONOMIC
INDEPENDENCE AND FREEDOM THAT
WE'VE USED TO ADVANCE OUR
STANDING IN SOCIETY TODAY.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT ISSUE I
TECHNOLOGIES CREATE AIDED
ANOTHER DOOR TO THE HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM AND IS AN AVENUE THAT
PROVIDERS ARE USING TO REACH
PATIENTS WHERE THEY ARE AND IN A
WAY THAT THEY WANT TO ACCESS
CARE.
RIGHT NOW IN ORDER FOR WOMEN TO
ORDER BIRTH CONTROL VIA A
SMARTPHONE APPS YOU MUST FIRST
SCHEDULE A VIDEO CONFERENCE.
THIS IS PROVEN TO BE A BARRIER
THAT HAD THE PROFESSIONALS
CONSIDERED TO BE MEDICALLY
UNNECESSARY SO WHAT AB TWELVE
SIXTY FOUR DOES IS.
CLARIFIED THAT HE SYNCHRONOUS
VIDEO CONFERENCE IS NOT REQUIRED
TO PROVIDE BIRTH CONTROL AND
THAT A APPROPRIATE PRIOR EXAM
COULD INCLUDE AN ASYNCHRONOUS
QUESTIONNAIRE.
PLANNED PARENTHOOD HEALTH CARE
CENTERS THIS WILL SIGNIFICANT
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE ACCESS TO
BIRTH CONTROL.
ON AND WE BELIEVE THAT IT'S AN
APPROPRIATE SHIFT IN THE
GUIDELINES WE MESS UPDATER COULD
SECTIONS REFLECTOR CHANGING
TECHNOLOGIES AND TO ALLOW PEOPLE
TO ORDER CONTRACEPTIVES.
I HOWEVER THEY ARE ABLE TO DO SO.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND I'M PLEASED TO
INTRODUCE OUR SPONSOR HERE TO
TESTIFY MOLLY ROBSON WITH
PLANNED PARENTHOOD VERY GOOD
THANK YOU [inaudible]
PLEASE.
I MOTHER OF THEM WITH PLANNED
PARENTHOOD I WE REPRESENT SEVEN
AFFILIATES WHO PROVIDE HEALTH
CARE TO OVER SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND PATIENTS IN CALIFORNIA --
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
HER LEADERSHIP AND COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THE ANALYSIS AND WORK
ON THE AMENDMENTS.
I WANNA MAKE ONE CLARIFICATION
WHICH IS ON PAGE THREE OF THE
ANALYSIS -- CURRENTLY PP DIRECT
DOES NOT PROVIDE STD TEST KITS
IN CALIFORNIA.
DIRECT EXIST IN MANY STATES --
AND SERVICES VERY SO JUST.
FYI -- BUT WE ARE SPONSORING
THIS BILL THE RIGHT CLARITY IN
THE LAW RELATED TO PRESCRIBING
MEDICATIONS VIA TELEHEALTH SUCH
AS BIRTH CONTROL -- AFTER
WORKING WITH STAKEHOLDERS WE
BROUGHT IN THE BILL TO CLARIFY
THAT.
APPROPRIATE PRIOR EXAMINATION
AND PRESCRIBING VIA TELEHEALTH
GENERALLY.
SO DESPITE CONTINUED INVESTMENTS
AND HEALTH CARE THROUGH THE
STATE BUDGET.
WE KNOW THAT THEY'RE STILL AN
UNMET NEED FOR BIRTH CONTROL IN
CALIFORNIA AND TELL HEALTH CAN
HELP -- WITH THIS BARRIER.
AND AS YOU KNOW THE GOAL OF
TELEHEALTH IS TO PROVIDE THE
SAME STANDARD OF CARE IN A WAY
PATIENTS WANT TO ACCESS CARE AS
THE AUTHOR MENTION.
RECOGNIZING THIS WE CREATED PP
DIRECT THROUGH PLANNED
PARENTHOOD -- TO PROVIDE BIRTH
CONTROL THROUGH AN ASYNCHRONOUS
A STORM FOR TECHNOLOGY.
THE OP LUNCHEON CALIFORNIA IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN AND HOT OVER FIVE
HUNDRED PATIENTS ON AVERAGE A
MONTH.
BUT DO THE AMBIGUITY IN THE LOT
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE WERE IT
BEGAN REQUIRING SYNCHRONOUS
VIDEO CONFERENCE BETWEEN PATIENT
AND CLINICIAN.
THIS IS AN OBLIGATION REQUIRED
IN FIFTEEN OTHER STATES THAT USE
THE PP DIRECT OP.
I MEDICAL EXPERTS AS MENTIONED
HAVE DETERMINED THAT IT'S
UNNECESSARY.
THIS APP IS MEETING PATIENTS
WHERE THEY ARE BUT THE
REQUIREMENT FOR VIDEO CONFERENCE
CAUSE A DISRUPTION CARE AND AN
ESTIMATED 50% OF PATIENTS WERE
NOT FULFILLING THE REQUIREMENT
TO GET THE BIRTH CONTROL.
AB TWELVE SIXTY FOUR PROVIDES
CLARITY THE NEW APPROPRIATE FOR
EXAMINATION IS TO BE DETERMINED
BY THE MEDICAL LICENSE FEE.
AND A SYNCHRONOUS REAL TIME AS
IT IS NOT REQUIRED TO DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT TO PROVIDE
HOMEOWNER BIRTH CONTROL TO A
PATIENT -- THIS APPLE OUT PP
DIRECTED ME THAN UNMET NEED AND
PROVIDE ACCESS TO TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF PATIENTS IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND THAT'S BENEFIT FROM
ASYNCHRONOUS TELEHEALTH AS
ORIGINALLY IMAGINED IN THE
CREATION OF THE APPLICATION.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
OF THIS BILL I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT VERY GOOD THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
BRICE DOUGHERTY WITH KP PUBLIC
AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF RO.
A TELL HEALTH INNOVATOR AND
THEIR MEN'S LINE ROMAN AND THEIR
WOMEN'S HEALTH LINE RORY AND ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
AMY DURBIN AT THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN FAVOR.
ANYWAY THIS IS IN OPPOSITION.
THE NON WILL BRING THE MATTER
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE -- I
WANTED TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD I I
THINK IT'S A IT'S AN EXCELLENT
BILL AN IMPORTANT BILL.
THERE'S THE OPPORTUNITY GOING
FORWARD -- TO ADELINE CO AUTHORS
I'D LOVE TO I JOIN IN IN YOUR
EFFORT WONDERFUL THANK YOU
EITHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS --
SENATOR ACTUAL -- CENTER PAN.
THE QUESTION REMOVED.
OKAY.
I'VE BEEN A RECOGNIZED EMOTION
YEAH BUT I DO RECOGNIZE YOU TO
ASK A QUESTION OR MAKE A COMMENT
SENATOR PAT.
THANK YOU VIOLET THE GOT THANK
YOU CHAIR ALL RIGHT -- THE FIRST
VOIGTS.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD I UNDERSTAND THIS IS
SPECIFICALLY -- FOR SELF
ADMINISTER HOME AUTO CON
REBUTTAL CONTRACEPTIVES CORRECT.
RIGHT YES OKAY AND AND I THINK
CERTAINLY WELL BECAUSE I THINK
THAT'S MY WELL THERE MAY BE
OTHER MEDICATIONS WHERE THIS
WOULD BE APPROPRIATE FOR TO I
JUST WANT.
THIS PARTICULAR CLASS OF
MEDICATION CLEARLY HAS BEEN
SHOWN TO BE SAFE EFFICACIOUS SO
WE KNOW THAT THERE.
ACTUALLY ARE PROFESSIONAL SIZE
OF RECOMMENDED THE OVER THE
COUNTER -- AND SO FR VARIOUS
REASONS -- PERHAPS -- THEY'RE
NOT -- BUT CERTAINLY I I THINK
THAT THIS IS A VERY APPROPRIATE
WAY TO EXPAND ACCESS AND
CERTAINLY -- WOODARD SUPPORT FOR
THE BILL.
THANK.
FORGET ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS NOT I I FEEL EMOTION
FROM MY RIGHT.
I THOUGHT IT WAS BUT I WILL SAY
IT AGAIN I'D LIKE TO FEEL FREE.
I MUST NOT HAVE BEEN A LOT OF
THEM.
SENATOR LEYVA HAS MOVED THIS
BILL.
AND WITH THAT OF THE SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL.
MISSION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE GLAZER
AYE GLAZER AYE CHIANG.
CHANG AYE ARCHULETA.
OUR TO LET AYE DOT I THOUGHT I
GALGIANI.
PHIL.
HILL AYE LEYVA.
THE THE AYE PAN HI CAN I WILK.
OKAY.
EVERYBODY YEAH GET ENOUGH ON
THIS ONE OKAY AS PLENTY OF US TO
GET OUR HOLDER OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
WRITING YOUR BILL IS SO MUCH.
ALL RIGHT NEXT UP IS.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN ASSEMBLY
BILL TWELVE NINETY ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES SAWYER
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
CAN BE ANYTIME YOU'RE READY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
I FIRST WANT TO THANK. TO START
BY THANKING THE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
ON THIS BILL.
AND I ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE OF
AMENDMENTS AB TWELVE NINETY ONE
CLARIFIES THE TIME FRAME FOR
WHEN CAMPUS BUSINESSES NEED TO
COMPLY WITH LABOR PEACE
AGREEMENT REQUIREMENTS.
A LABOR PEACE AGREEMENT S AN
AGREEMENT BETWEEN A BUSINESS AND
LABOR ORGANIZATIONS THAT
PRESCRIBED ALLEGATION OF EACH
PARTY.
THESE AGREEMENTS TEND TO INCLUDE
MUTUALLY BENEFICIAL PROVISIONS
THAT PROTECT BUSINESSES AND
IMPORTANTLY EMPLOYEES CURRENT
LAW REQUIRES THAT CANNABIS
BUSINESSES WITH TWENTY OR MORE
EMPLOYEES ENTER LABOR PEACE
AGREEMENT.
AS PART OF THE APPLICATION
PROCESS TO OBTAIN A CANVAS
LICENSE BUSINESSES WITH AT LEAST
TWENTY EMPLOYEES ARE REQUIRED TO
STATE THAT THEY WILL ENTER LABOR
PEACE AGREEMENT IF THE BUSINESS
AT ALL IT'S NOT ALREADY ENTERED.
ONE HOWEVER CURRENT REGULATIONS
ARE SILENT.
ONLY BUSINESSES WITH LESS THAN
TWENTY EMPLOYEES NEED TO ENTER A
LABOR PEACE AGREEMENT.
IF THEY BECOME EMPLOYERS OF
TWENTY OR MORE REGULATIONS ONLY
SAY THIS REQUIREMENT NEEDS NEEDS
TO BE WILL BE MET AS SOON AS
REASONABLY PRACTICABLE.
WHICH IS VAGUE AND ALL OPEN TO
INTERPRETATION AB TWELVE NINETY
ONE WILL REQUIRE CANNABIS
BUSINESS LICENSE.
APPLICANTS EMPLOYING LESS THAN
TWENTY EMPLOYEES TO SUBMIT A
STATEMENT THAT WILL ENTER A
LABOR PEACE AGREEMENT WITHIN
SIXTY DAYS OF EMPLOYING THEIR
TWENTIETH EMPLOYEE.
THIS MEASURE WILL PROTECT
ARBITRARY ENFORCEMENT AGAINST
CANVAS BUSINESSES AND WILL
PROVIDE EMPLOYEES WITH CLARITY --
WHEN AN EMPLOYER IS BAILEY TO
COMPLY WITH THIS LAW WITH ME
TODAY? TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
HIS MEASURES JAZZY GRAY WALL
FROM U. S. E. W. MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR RIFLE
THANK YOU FOR THE PRESENTATION
YOUR FIRST WITNESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
JAZZY GRAVEL WITH UFCW WESTERN
STATES COUNSEL HERE ON BEHALF OF
OUR THOUSANDS OF CANADA'S
MEMBERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
I'M I'M HERE TO HELP -- HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MIGHT HAVE ADDRESS ANY CONCERNS.
YOU HAVE WITH THE BILLS I THINK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN FAVOR STEP UP TO
THE MICROPHONE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MITCH SNIDER WITH CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MAP BROUGHT
WITH THE TEAMSTERS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN FAVOR.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
CNN WILL BRING THE MATTER BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS.
VICE YOUR CHECK.
THIS IS A THIS BILL SIMPLY
CLARIFIES WHAT IS ALREADY IN
CURRENT LAW.
RIGHT IT IS CLEAR FIGHT WITH THE
TIME LINE.
RECORD FOR THE TIMELINE MAKE
SURE THERE'S NO AMBIGUITY OR
MISINTERPRETATION AS YOU MOVE
FOR WHEN THE COMPANY GETS LARGER
WHICH WE HOPE WILL BE ALL OF
THANK YOU.
THAT ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS --
SEPTEMBER RELIGION CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
OKAY.
SO THAT THERE IS A MOTION I'LL
TAKE IT IS DO PASS AS AMENDED.
TO SENATE LABOR PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT EVERY TIME -- OKAY.
WITH THAT SECRETARY CALL THE
ROLL.
GLAZER HI.
THERE I CHANGE.
CHIANG AYE FOR TO LET US.
I TO LET AYE DOT [inaudible]
I GALGIANI.
THEY'LL.
FILL AYE LEYVA.
THE BY PAN HI CAN I WILK HI OKAY.
WE GET PLENTY OF US KNEW THAT
THE LONG THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE AND WE'LL.
CLOSE IT OUT WHEN ALL OF OUR
APPS MEMBERS ARE HERE THANK YOU
DAY THANK YOU.
THE CIVIC.
CENTER.
YEAH.
I THINK.
THE NO.
WHO WILL ARE YOU AWARE OF ALL
RIGHT WE'RE WE'VE COME TO THE
LAST BILL ON OUR AGENDA TODAY?
ITEM NUMBER THREE ASSEMBLY BILL
FOUR SEVENTY SIX FIVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLANCA RUBIO WELCOME TO
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU I YOU
KNOW I FORGOT HOW EFFICIENT THE
SENATE IS.
THAT SHOULDN'T REQUIRE A MARIE
ISSUE BUT OKAY WHAT THE HECK
THEY'RE HAPPY TO HAVE YOU HERE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I MISSED
HEARING COMMITTEE MEMBERS TODAY
I'M PRESENTING AB FOR SEVENTY
SIX WHICH CREATED TASK FORCE
THAT WILL STUDY AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON HOW TO
INTEGRATE.
FOREIGN TRAINED PROFESSIONALS
AND HOW TO ELIMINATE.
UNNECESSARY BARRIERS FOR FOREIGN
OF PROFESSIONALS THIS BILL WILL --
IS A REINTRODUCTION OF AB EIGHT
TWENTY SEVEN FROM.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN CURRENT LAW
PROVIDES FOR THE LIGHT LICENSE
SUGAR AND REGULATION OF VARIOUS
PROFESSIONALS AND VOCATIONAL BY
BOARDS WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS.
I HOWEVER SOME IMMIGRANTS HAVE
COMPLAINED ABOUT THE PROCESS
HAVING MULTIPLE BARRIERS IN
TERMS OF PROCESS TIMELINESS A
DEGREE OF EVALUATION AND
ACCEPTANCE OF FOREIGN
CREDENTIALS.
ON THIS IS BEEN GOING ON WE HAVE
A LOT OF QUALIFIED OF FOREIGN
PROFESSIONALS THAT ARE HAVING A
REALLY DIFFICULT TIME TRYING TO
TRANSFER THEIR CREDENTIALS.
AND WE ARE IN NEED OF OF A LOT
OF THE POSITIONS THAT ARE BEING --
YOU KNOW WITH THE BARRIERS ARE
ARE BEING PRESENTED TO SOUL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
CONSIDERATION FOR AN FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GIVE WITNESSES IN FAVOR HI
CHRISTY CHRIS FOR SIGNS OF THE
CHAIR OF THE COALITION FOR
HUMANE IMMIGRANT RIGHTS PROBABLY
A SPONSOR THIS MEASURE -- THERE
IS ROUGHLY ABOUT TWO MILLION
IMMIGRANTS WILL HAVE WORK
AUTHORIZATION AND I I'M 40% OF
THOSE IMMIGRANTS ARE ACT HOW
POSTSECONDARY DEGREES I COULD
ACTUALLY BE UTILIZED IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
HOWEVER COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE
EXPRESSED FRUSTRATION AND RUN
INTO BARRIERS -- IN OBTAINING
THOSE LICENSES AND THE
PROFESSION -- INCLUDING DEGREE
EVALUATION THE LACK OF
CENTRALIZED INFORMATION THE
PROCESS ARE ARM IN THE PROCESS
DOES HINDER ONE'S ABILITY TO
MOVE FORWARD ESPECIALLY GIVEN
THAT MANY OF THESE CALIFORNIANS
ARE WORKING CLASS AND I'M
DIFFICULTIES.
AND TAKING TIME OFF TO THE
FINANCIAL OBLIGATIONS THIS BILL
IS A PARTICULAR PART IN DURING
THESE TIMES AS THE LEGAL
IMMIGRATION PROCESS CONTINUES TO
DECREASE UNDER THIS
ADMINISTRATION.
INCLUDING THE ISSUANCE OF H. ONE
B. VISAS WHICH ARE -- USE FOR
HIGH SKILLED WORKERS IN FACT THE
SACRAMENTO REGION IS ONE OF THE
TOP FIVE REGIONS IN THE NATION
THAT UTILIZES H. ONE B. V. SO
WORKERS.
IN THE NEAR FUTURE CALIFORNIA
MAKES THE AVOIDANCE WORK FORCE --
DUE TO THE LACK OF RECRUITMENT
OF HIGH SKILLED WORKERS IN THIS
FOR THESE REASONS WE ASK.
FOR WEIRD FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN FAVOR.
ARE YOU GET ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
BRING THE MATTER BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS -- ASSEMBLY WOMAN MADE
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD I I'M SURE AS MANY
PEOPLE HERE HAVE RELATIVES OR
FRIENDS -- QUITE QUALIFIED AND
OF RUN INTO THESE BARRIERS AND
AS YOU HAVE CORRECTLY IDENTIFIED.
AT A TIME WHERE WE NEED MORE
PROFESSIONALS IN THESE FIELDS --
IT'S FRUSTRATING THAT WE HAVEN'T
FOUND A PROCESS TO TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THEIR TRAINING AND
EXPERTISE -- MAKE SURE THEY MEET
ALL THE STANDARDS OF OF CARE
THAT WE WOULD EXPECT -- AND GET
THEM INTO THE WORK FORCE IN A
WAY THAT HELPS OUR COMMUNITY AND
SO I THANK YOU IF THERE'S A
OPPORTUNITY DOWN THE ROAD.
WHICH MAY NOT BE FOR AMENDMENTS
I CERTAINLY WOULD ENJOY THE END
CAN PARK RANGERS COMMA IF YOU
WOULD LIKE.
THE HAPPY DO I I'D BE PLEASING
KIA BECAUSE CO SPONSOR OF YOUR
IMPORTANT MEASURE THANK YOU I
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT -- AND
YOU KNOW JUST TO KNOW WE DID
RECEIVE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
THE ASSEMBLY AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR THE SAME
HERE I'LL TAKE THAT AS YOUR
CLOTHES.
SENATOR ARCHULETA MOVES THE BILL
THIS WOULD BE -- DO PASSED THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS THAT THE
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
GLAZER AYE GLAZER AYE CHIANG.
CHING AYE ARE TO LET US.
ARCHULETA AYE DODD AYE THOUGHT I
GALGIANI.
NAY HILL.
WELL I LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE PAN ALL RIGHT CAN I
WILL.
OKAY THAT HAS PLENTY OF US TO
GET OUR HOLDER OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
COMING THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
MEMBERS -- THAT COMPLETES OUR
AGENDA TODAY WE'RE GOING TO GO
THROUGH THE ROLE SO MEMBERS CAN
ADD ON SO WITH THAT WHEN WE
STARTED -- AT THE TOP ITEM
NUMBER ONE ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURKE
AT THE SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL
MISSION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE.
SIX TWO ZERO CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR VOTING I DODD.
DODD AYE GALGIANI.
FAN THANK YOU CAN I RIGHT THAT
WE'RE GONNA IT'S EIGHT EIGHT
VOTES IN FAVOR WILL HOLD A
LITTLE CONTRAPTION MEMBERS. ONE
SECOND PLEASE [inaudible]
RIGHT THANK.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO
ITEM NUMBER TWO AB TWO FORTY
FIVE FIVE TWO KEY.
SECRETARY WOULD CALL THE ROLL
MISSION IS TO PASSAGE GEO
COMMITTEE.
RIGHT BUT SIX ZERO CHAIR AND
VICE CHAIR READING I DODD.
DODD AYE GALGIANI.
PAN HI CAN I HE'S GOT A VOTES
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS MOVING ON ITEM
NUMBER THREE ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
SEVEN SIX WITH -- EVERYBODY'S
BEEN HERE FOR THAT RIGHT SO
WE'LL SKIP THAT.
ONE ITEM FOR ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
EIGHTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHAD SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
MOTIONS TO PASS AS A MINUTE A
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
KERR ABOUT.
SIX ZERO DOT HI DODD AYE
GALGIANI.
PAN ALL RIGHT CAN I ARTS GOT
ABLE HOLD IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS WILL BE LINE ITEM SIX A.
B..
TWELVE SIXTY FOUR SECRETARY CALL
THE ROLL THE THING [inaudible]
BRISTOL ANYTHING.
ALL RIGHT WELL HOLD OUT ONE THAT
HAS -- EIGHT SAME WITH.
SEVEN AND HOW BUT ITEM.
FOURTEEN OKAY ALL RIGHT.
SO -- COLLEAGUES THOSE WHO HAVE
BEEN.
SO ATTENTIVE AND AND AND HEAR AN
ATTENDANCE YOU'RE ALL CLEAR
WE'RE GONNA HOLD THE ROLE OPEN
FOR JUST ANOTHER.
COUPLE MINUTES FOR ONE ABSENCE
SENATOR AND AND WITH THAT --
STATUS
.
IN SESSION HERE I'M GONNA GO
THROUGH EACH OF THE ITEMS THAT
WE HAVE HEARD THAT.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE BY
BURKE THAT IS THAT BILLS OUT.
EIGHT ZERO ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
FORTY FIVE A MERIT TO CHI THAT
BILLS OUT.
EIGHT ZERO ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
SEVEN SIX BY SELLING WOMAN
BLANCA RUBIO THAT BILLS OUT.
EIGHT ZERO ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
EIGHTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHEN THAT BILL IS OUT.
EIGHT ZERO ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE
SIXTY FOUR BY PETRIE-NORRIS THAT
BILLS OUT.
EIGHT ZERO ASSEMBLY BILL.
TWELVE NINETY ONE THAT THAT BILL
IS OUT.
EIGHT ZERO AND FINALLY ASSEMBLY
BILL -- FOURTEEN TWENTY THAT
BILL IS OUT SEVEN ZERO THAT
COMPLETES OUR BUSINESS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU OFFER.
ATTENDING LISTENING OR WATCHING
AND WITH THAT THE MEETING IS
ADJOURNED